[Musique]
et tout de suite le planète people
c est ce que c'est le planète people
bien évidemment je suis cette émission
régulièrement tous les mercredis je suis
dans l'émission temps c'est le samedi
tous les bons dans tous les sens c'est
je sais bien maintenant je regarde
complicité démonstrative entre le
président français et son homologue
américain joe biden à la reconquête de
l'ouest emmanuel macron en opération
séduction
what you vois-tu démontrer à tous les
deux chiffres il se borne à chypre et
que je l'étais avant nous sommes de
retour les etats-unis sont de retour
alors que les pays occidentaux rouvrent
leurs frontières celles de la chine
reste résolument fermés notamment aux
français puisque les autorités chinoises
considèrent toujours la france comme un
pays à risque
résultat venir ou revenir en chine
relève du parcours du combattant il faut
deux tests pcr et sérologique avant de
monter dans l'avion généralement des
tests à l'arrivée parfois dans un
hôpital avec testan à les radios des
poumons
chaque fois que lui chez cymes
m'expliquer ce qui va me faire je ne
suis pas rassuré mais ça c'est encore
autre chose si ce n'est dans aucun
surtout qu'est ce que tu dis je ne suis
pas rassuré voilà le geste que tu fais
dans aucun des trains à la une également
une gifle qui fait le tour du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand je vois le tapage qu'on a fait
autour de cette histoire un qui est
surtout à mettre au débit des gardes du
corps du président je pense qu'ils ont
été extrêmement léger de laisser partir
le président comme ça vers une grille
ouverte avec bon bref ça c'est un autre
sujet mais je pense que ce tapage fait
autour de cette petite caresse un peu
appuyé sur l'ajout du président m'a un
peu choqué vous minimisez tout de suite
aussi le fait ou dit c'est une caresse
appuyé sur l'ajout du présent sûrement à
monsieur j'ai grandi à marseille et je
vous assure que ce genre de choses ça
fait rigoler tout le monde à marseille
voyez moi fois que j'ai pris le métro
j'ai dit bonjour
ouais et puis ensuite je me suis rendu
compte que ce n'était pas forcément dans
les habitudes des parisiens des bus à
marseille je sais pas si je crois qu on
est quand même un petit peu plus voilà
j'aurai pas dire accueillant je voudrais
pas blesser les parisiens mais on a un
truc de chaleur très naturel il faut
accepter la laine de l'autre c'est le
respect c'est dans l'adversité
l'acceptation l'acceptation
[Musique]
du travail de pro
on voit bien la marque satanique qui
représenterait une victoire du
rassemblement national gérald darmanin
était hier en déplacement à dijon le
journal de saône et loire a rapporté ses
propos
daisy hier sur son site internet marine
le pen a réagi et regretté la sortie du
ministre de l'intérieur
mais pour une raison qui ne cessera de
m'étonner aucun média ne revient ce
matin sur les paroles de gérald darmanin
puisque l'heure est à la re
diabolisation du r'n s est ce qu'on peut
croire et c'est ce que peut-être a su
gérer gérald darmanin qui hier en
déplacement en bourgogne a déclaré
qu'une victoire du r'n dans une région
ce serait une marque sataniste
j'ai écouté toutes les matinales et
personne n'a cru bon rapporté ce micro
événement sauf ses news
depuis le début de cette campagne des
ministres ont appelé à chasser le
rassemblement national à abattre
l'ennemi qu'est marine le pen
aujourd'hui nous sommes accusés de
satanisme il faut que la république en
marche garde son calme
d'un côté nous avons donc un exécutif
qui se plaint de la violence qui
regrettent des paroles outrancières qui
invite à la modération et de l'autre un
ministre gérald darmanin qui compare le
rassemblement national à satan sans que
personne ne bronche dans la classe
médiatique
j'en conclus que ça n'interpelle ou que
ça ne choque que moi et qui m'ont
logiciel n'est pas bon pour analyser
décrypter commenter la vie politique de
ce pays on a encore entendu tout à
l'heure il est assez cocasse d'entendre
des cris de vierge effarouchée des
politiques qu'ils ont eux mêmes par
leurs excès verbaux leurs surenchères
nourrissait de violence alors il serait
peut-être temps qu'il cesse de jouer
avec le feu et avec la détresse des gens
ce sans doute dans l'intérêt de tout le
monde on risque d'avoir une campagne
présidentielle absolument immonde
nous sommes en relation avec le diable
ce matin il est avec nous nous lui avons
demandé de venir
robert ménard et là bonjour robert
ménard bonjour bonjour vous êtes
exorcise heures non
vous dire c'est que vous êtes le diable
s'est dit s'attendre sur 6 e
bon mais dans une matière dense dans un
monde où effectivement c'est très
stéréotypé donc là on veut l'acceptation
de soi pour l'acceptent y avait un
réseau social où l'important c'était la
photo est sûre le et sur lequel on se
prenait en photo comme ça pour une
lumière et on pourrait prendre des
photos de son dessert par exemple ça se
saurait franchement ça serait on en est
heureusement pas encore là en train de
prendre un temps noté 6 étoiles aux
maldives
je vais pas perdre mon temps à faire à
manger c'est quelque chose qui me plaît
pas je n'arrive pas à faire à manger
j'ai essayé plusieurs plusieurs fois en
vain et c'est sans fin elle en rajoute
une couche
[Musique]
tu sais pas faire à manger je fais pas à
manger je suis riche ce n'est pas
bordeaux mais amiens qui arrive en tête
des dix villes les plus heureuses de
france devant strasbourg et avignon
c'est en tout cas le résultat d'une
étude menée grâce à un programme
d'intelligence artificielle 220000
selphy publié sur instagram ont été
analysés à la recherche des visages les
plus souriants une méthodologie qui vaut
ce qu'elle vaut et qui sur le plan
mondial
his chicago à la première place ne
pourra pas de régénérer tout de suite là
parce que j'ai passé ni
l'artiste de 27 ans explore également
l'ennui et la procrastination dans le
monde administratif comme dans cette
performance de 2018
intitulée corps de métier où elle révèle
le sex-appeal des objets de bureau je
veux toujours pouvoir aller chercher mon
papier toilette au supermarché ça c'est
clair comme ça n'est pas changé depuis
pour garder cette station très belle
citation
j'ai vu des mecs c'est aussi parfois un
petit peu les choses qui se rapproche
plutôt de baudelaire j'ai pleuré de
l'era vous savez qu'on va faire le
zapping là